en febrero tran dijo que el cob y 19
podría desaparecer milagrosamente en
abril
este es sólo uno de los comentarios que
donald trump ha hecho desde el comienzo
del brote de coronavirus para descartar
la gravedad de la situación hemos hecho
un trabajo increíble
vamos a continuar va a desaparecer algún
día como un milagro
a pesar de las pocas pruebas de su
eficacia trump ha elogiado abiertamente
la hidroxi cloroquina como una forma de
evitar el kobe 19 una droga antimalaria
que él mismo ha dicho haber tomado en
abril pareció sugerir otros tratamientos
no verificados y dañinos como inyectarse
desinfectante aunque tran dijo más tarde
que los comentarios eran irónicos de ese
efecto supongamos que impactamos el
cuerpo con una tremenda luz ultravioleta
o sólo una luz muy poderosa
luego el desinfectante que lo elimina en
un minuto un minuto hay alguna manera de
que podamos hacer algo así por medio de
una inyección en el interior o una
limpieza
a medida que los casos comenzaron a
aumentar y que varias partes
eeuu fueron confinadas los expertos en
salud subrayaron la importancia del
distanciamiento social y el uso de
máscaras prácticas subestimadas en gran
medida durante los mítines de la campaña
trump como en este de junio el propio
presidente rara vez fue visto con una
máscara sólo en julio fue visto por
primera vez usando una en público ya me
había puesto una antes me la puse en
esta zona de atrás pero no quería dar a
la prensa el placer de ver verse según
trump eeuu ha pasado lo peor de la
pandemia que ha matado a más de 200.000
estadounidenses sin embargo sus propios
expertos en salud han dado a menudo
evaluaciones menos positivas de la
situación del país